CBS News political contributor Bob
Schieffer has covered the bush family's
political fortunes and private
contributions to American life for more
than 40 years he spoke to mrs. Bush in
1988 her first interview after her
husband announced he would run for
president
Bob is with us from Washington Bob so
good to have you with us this morning
you think about Barbara Bush and one of
the things that comes to mind is her
kids calling her the enforcer and she
really was I mean any one of them would
tell you that you know their father they
respected him greatly and they were
always worried about disappointing him
but they were scared of her and I can
tell you that for a fact I mean they
loved her to death but she was the one
who made the rules in the family and she
was the one who enforced them and I'm
telling you she could stare down a
grizzly bear but at the same time she
loved children and she'd love to be
around them when visitors used to come
to Kennebunkport in the summertime she
would sometimes sit a 10 or 12 year old
child next to the President of the
United States and and she was interested
in all children and especially her
children and her grandchildren Bob what
struck you about that 1988 interview
when you interviewed her when her
husband was running for president well
she she was she was you know she knew
who she was and she was very comfortable
with herself and she was not afraid to
say out loud what other people might be
thinking I mean there had been a big
story going around Newsweek and run a
cover that George Bush was a wimp and it
said overcoming the wimp factor and I
asked her about it in that interview and
she said he's not a wimp but if he is we
need a lot of wimps because he is one
tough wimp
Bob she may have been born in New York
but us Texans like to gladly claim her
as one of our own talk about the role
she played as a confidante and advisor
to her husband well she was a confidante
who gave her advice to the president she
was not going on television and and
spelling out what he ought to do or what
he ought not to do but what I always
remember her for is is I mean she didn't
suffer fools gladly and she at some
points could be very off-putting to
people if she didn't agree with them but
she was the mom she was the one in
charge of that family and you know this
long life that they had one of the
things that together I think a lot of
people don't know about when George Bush
George HW Bush her husband was playing
baseball at Yale she loved baseball and
she used to keep all of his she she kept
score and she had all of his the box
scores of all the games he played at
Yale she taught George W Bush how to
keep score in baseball and then when the
grandkids came along she she she taught
them how to keep scores she still had
and I'm supposed somewhere in her and
her property there she still has all of
the box scores of george w bush's
baseball games when he played in Little
League
she was really a fan right up until they
absolutely love love hearing those
stories Bob you know in the final final
days of her life we learned that while
she was battling heart failure she did
also enjoy her favorite bourbon
what does that tell us about Barbara
Bush and I don't think she'd be ashamed
for you to know that because that's
that's the kind of person she was she
was who she was and as I say she was
quite a formidable person all right bob
thanks may we all have a bourbon at hand
after a life like that thanks the flag
at the White House is at half-staff this
morning in memory of Barbara Bush
President Trump
ordered flags to be lowered at all
government buildings and military
outposts president and first lady said
in a statement that they joined the
nation in celebrating the life of an
advocate of the American family